des vétérans demande des comptes il
avait participé à des campagnes d'essais
nucléaires et certains souffrent
aujourd'hui de cancers ils viennent de
créer une association et il demande donc
maintenant un peu de transparence dans
leurs dossiers enquête de christophe
nardini et marc savinaud 1960 base de
reggane au coeur du sahara
la france prépare son premier essai
nucléaire le 13 février à 7h04 gerboise
bleue explose
une bombe aussi puissante que celle
d'hiroshima à 40 kilomètres du point
zéro 5000 personnes sont présentes
relents veille se souvient des gestes de
sécurité
ils étaient appelés du contingent
tailleur de dos à la tour il faille se
boucher les cachets des vignes pour ne
pas voir les yeux brûlés par le lait
caire et ouvrir la bouche pour faire le
tapin il éclate lorsque le sont à
l'arrêt et après une fois tant 4000 ne
va pas nous sommes levés sommes partis
en courant vers le lot la falaise et on
courait comme ça moi je courais comme ça
et au moment du choc est arrivé dans
notre position et il y avait comme moi
il y avait la puissance par terre c'est
un vrai champ de bataille de cette
époque roland veille à garder quelques
photos des portraits de camarades dont
certains sont aujourd'hui disparus
et puis il y a ceux gants en coton seul
vestige de sa combinaison protection
toute la tenue était fait de cette de ce
matériau de ce coton tout était comme ça
alors protégé de commandes de quoi je me
venge sur son livret militaire encore
incomplet qu'il s'est difficilement
procurer une mention indique clairement
qu'il a été irradié
ce qui est moins clair c'est la dose qui
l'a reçu on peut lire 1100 milliards ngn
ou 15000 sommes ihringen pour lui en
tout cas cette dose est la cause de tous
ces ennuis de santé jusqu'aux plus
important 87 l'ablation de la thyroïde
une maladie pour laquelle l'armée ne
reconnaît pas sa responsabilité
refusant ainsi le principe de
présomption d'origine pourtant prévue
par la loi française
la loi demande simplement qu'il faut
prouver qu'on a bien été exposé eca
bâtiment exposé il faut prouver qu'on a
bien eu la maladie dans les délais
habituels et ça suffit c'est ce qu'on
appelle la présomption d'origine
grâce à cette présomption d'origine à ce
moment là l'état c'est normal considère
que c'est un accident du travail et donc
donne une compensation financière
mais là le problème avec l'armée sait
que c'est impossible parce que c' est ce
mécanisme simple n'existe pas dans la
loi militaire après le sahara l'armée
continuera ses essais dans le pacifique
de nombreux soldats développeront des
maladies suspecte l'armée aujourd'hui
n'établit toujours aucun lien elle
commande même un rapport à l'inserm et
malgré les conclusions de cette étude
elle rejette toute relation entre cancer
et distance par rapport aux sites de
tirs mais il ya des gens qui ont
effectivement utilisé le rapport de
manière quoi on aurait été en
contredisant les conclusions du rapport
que sur un an sens dénoncé par certains
militaires qui ont participé aux essais
pour cela il s'appuie entre autres sur
une étude britannique
elles montrent qu' au moins un sur trois
des vétérans est décédé avant l'âge de
60 ans que 1 sur 7 n'a pas pu avoir
d'enfants que les enfants et petits
enfants des vétérans ont des
conséquences pathologiques semblable à
celle des vétérans eux mêmes
la france a procédé à 210 essais
nucléaires officiellement il n'y a pas
eu de victimes mais aujourd'hui 150
vétérans se sont regroupés en
association ils réclament une loi qui
reconnaissent le lien entre certains
types de cancer et leur participation à
ces essais cela pourrait concerner
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
bataille